what we've done is we've we've taken
$7,500 from every American or 16 16,500
from every taxpayer $16,000 from every
taxpayer and then given some of those
taxpayers a check for $1,200 that that's
that's not helping we have taken two and
a half trillion dollars and only given
three hundred and fifty five billion to
small businesses where's the rest going
same place it went last time I'm Dave
Rubin and this is the Reuben report
joining me today is the founder of the
blaze the host of the Glenn Beck radio
program and the author of the new book
arguing with socialists Glenn Beck
welcome back to the Rubin report thanks
man how are you I'm all right you know
we are in the midst of a zombie
apocalypse then I'm in the People's
Republic of California so I probably
have a shorter life than you do but I'm
okay yeah yeah yeah I'm good I'm glad at
New York glad I'm not in LA you know
move to the center of the country for a
reason and this would be it this would
be it so I guess the first obvious
question here beyond just the general
how you do enduring Corona is as a guy
who's sort of been in mainstream media
and out of mainstream media and a
trailblazer in new media did you ever
think you'd be doing your show from home
like dave rubin does his show from home
all the time I tell you something Dave
it is because I've been in broadcast for
like 42 years now the technology and
what we can accomplish now we couldn't
have accomplished even 10 years ago it's
phenomenal it's really phenomenal how
how the power of the media really is in
the hands of the average person if they
care to take it it's really crazy
so how reading you in the middle of the
country where you are at least a little
kind of safe yeah it's it's pretty good
it's pretty good it's not New York thank
God
[Music]
Texas is still free thank god we've got
a good governor who is not trying to
tell everybody exactly what to do you
know being home with the kids because I
my kids live next door so we're kind of
quarantined together so we got nine of
us you know living at home which is this
is nice it's nice it's times where
you're like oh yeah I gotta go I gotta
get out of here but most of it is good
most of it is good so I know we could
get into the numbers about Corona and
all of that stuff well let's just put
that aside but let's talk about the
thing that I think mostly animates
almost everything that you and I do
which is which is freedom and liberty
so as we're hearing about lockdowns
being extended and just in the last
couple days we heard now in LA where I
am now we're at may 15 that we know
it'll go beyond that because it's not
like you just magically flip the switch
and suddenly we're all out there again
and we see this cascading across the
country how concerned are you that as we
just get more and more stuck in our
homes as we don't go out as we don't
socialize as we as you probably saw in
Michigan you can't buy seeds at stores
to plant your own game all of these
types of things I'm much more concerned
about that than I am the virus
specifically are you sort of in line
with that yeah so I said back in January
when we were starting to look at this
and I said this thing is gonna sweep
this looks like 1918 I said but it's not
what concerns me is not the death rate
what concerns me is what it will do to
the economy and what it can do to
freedom and I think that's I think
that's turning out to be accurate the
what what the Federal Reserve is done
what the government has done is
unprecedented and it's you know to
really fully understand it because the
the the
system of the free market is so complex
and while it has taken a beating for the
last 20 years it is very fragile and
it's as if we were all on a 747 a
brand-new Boeing 747 and and the pilot
said you know what it's gonna get really
really bumpy up here so what we're gonna
do some of you had maybe one could get a
concussion or die but there 400 of us on
this plane so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna turn the engines off and
right before we hit the ground we're
gonna turn him back on I wouldn't be for
that I would say maybe maybe a couple
people could bump their head and maybe
we could even lose a couple of people on
the plane I hate to say that but
nobody's ever turned the engines off in
hopes that you turn them on in exactly
the right time before it's just a pile
of rubble on the ground and that's what
they've done and I don't know how
effective it's going to be you know
they're talking about a via Cana me
where they just turn it off and then
pump money into it to preserve it and
then when you turn it back on it goes
straight back up it won't it won't go
straight back up it can't go straight
back up first of all you're losing you
know eighty percent of jobs that are
created or created by the small
businessman how many of them had enough
money just to pay the mortgage and their
rental on their machinery or their of
their restaurant they're not going to be
able to open up they're open they're
they're running on about a five percent
margin how many of those restaurants are
going to be able to a hold two months or
month and a half
then open back up when I don't know
about you day but I'm not gonna be going
running out to crowded restaurants right
away mm-hmm that's the last thing that
people are gonna do this is going to
affect us enormous Lee enormous Lee and
there's something else I yes go ahead go
ahead
well know so with that in mind so before
we get to some of the stuff that was
done wrong what what would be the right
thing
to do right now so if we're concerned
about all those small businesses I mean
I know you're not necessarily a ubi guy
you don't want the government to just be
handing cash to people but what is the
right thing to do then in a situation
like this so I'm not a ubi guy and I've
done a lot of looking into ubi because I
know what's coming with technology and
everything else and I am I'm much more
of a futurist than a nowis if you will
and so I have looked into ubi
it doesn't work however this is a
different situation I'm not talking
about universal basic income but this is
a different situation the the the crash
of o8 was caused by many things but the
government and the banks and then stupid
people listening to the government and
the banks that's why that was caused
that in greed it just caused that thing
to meltdown that wasn't my fault why was
i bailing out the banks it wasn't your
fault Dave why were you bailing out the
banks this is different
no nothing anyone did except for China
was this the government turned it off
for the first time in history and said
you cannot go to work
well article 5 of the Constitution says
you better give me some money because
you've just destroyed me so you have to
make me as whole as you possibly can so
I m4 in this particular case the
government coming up with ways to feed
money into the system and help those at
the lowest rung of the ladder including
those small businessmen who are just
barely making it now you've destroyed
them instead what we've done is we've
we've taken $7,500 from every American
or 16 16500 from every taxpayer $16,000
from every taxpayer and then given some
of those taxpayers a check for $1,200
that that's that's not helping we have
taken two and a half trillion dollars
and only given three hundred and fifty
five billion to small businesses
where's the rest going same place it
went last time
right so with that in mind is is this
just one of these things where our
system is so is so broken in so many
ways that every time we try to do
something to fix it
we just create more problems like we
yeah we extend it so we we survive 2008
but then we could we make - you know
banks are too big to fail what do we do
we make them bigger that we just create
bandaid on top of bandaid on top of
band-aid when my hope is that at that
this thing is so profoundly different
that maybe it actually will get people
to look at the root causes and think
about it all differently do you think
there's any chance or am I just a
dreamer I think you're a dreamer on that
one because the damage has already been
done and the system has already changed
I think it's been baked into the
response you know the Fed had prepared
this this was a prepared response you
can read it in their own notes they knew
exactly what they were doing when they
came in to the president and he said
we've got a quarantine the country what
do we do the Fed handed him a book and
said here's what we think should be done
they had already war gamed this to some
degree and so the change was already
baked into it let me give you some stats
the Federal Reserve is purchasing six
hundred and twenty five billion dollars
per week of US Treasury bonds that's our
debt plus us multiple municipal bonds
our city bonds and our corporate bonds
at that rate of spend the Federal
Reserve will own all outstanding US
public debt federal and local by
September of this year and all corporate
debt by December of this year they are
now pledging 200 billion dollars a month
the US banks plus fannie and freddie to
buy all distressed mortgages they are
officially today not in the future today
the largest landlord
in the world by the end of the year they
own almost everything so where do you go
where do you go for a free market
Deutsch a bank just said over the
weekend a few days ago that it was the
end of the free market there because of
the Federal Reserve there is no free
market and the bad thing is it's not the
Fed the Fed just did all this behind
closed doors did it without discussing
did it without any members of Congress
being involved and our treasury is the
one that guarantees everything so when
they all go bad it's on the taxpayer
again we are propping up the world as a
taxpayer and none of us have been
consulted it's really really dangerous
really dangerous so there's so much
stuff there but so for the average
person that you know they hear the Fed
they hear the numbers you just lay out
they hear debt to China all of these
things that you know you're the average
person you maybe have a job maybe don't
right now and you're trying to figure
out how to live your life but you want
to pay some level of attention to this
well is what do you do I mean what what
could we have done or what could we do
now to reverse any of this and and if
Trump was their job to drain the swamp
did he just did he just utterly fail
then no I don't think he I mean you
can't shut the engines off without
juicing the system you you had to put
the money and if your choice was tell
everybody to stay home
you had to juice the system the the
problem is I think this it was much I
think we took some of the wrong steps I
think listening to the Federal Reserve
and to the five biggest banks in the
world they were the ones that got all of
the candy meanwhile they are making it
more difficult just as they did in 2008
for people to go get a mortgage you need
the average person to be able to have
money instead why didn't we say to the
banks you know what you guys got bailed
out last time no mortgage payments for
any one business or home no mortgage
payments for
three months no college student loans no
loan payments for college students for
three months all of these things should
have been suspended instead people who
can't pay their rent are getting a check
for $1,200 well in New York that's not
going to do it
$1,200 is nothing in New York nothing
well $1,200 in New York for a little
perspective my my sister who lives in
New York City although she's not there
now lives in a one-bedroom converted
into a 2 so it's a fake 2-bedroom
apartment the rents around five grand a
month so what yeah just to give a little
perspective on that 1,200 so right what
what do we do so so the libertarian
classically liberal minded people that
are hearing okay so the Fed all of this
stuff is happening it's it's it's just
solving problems that they created the
rest of it what should the states be
doing so you mentioned you've got Abbott
there in Texas he's doing its seemingly
trying to protect some of your civil
liberties I've got a different problem
here gavin newsom in in california but
how do we decide in a time like this
what the states versus the Fed should be
doing I wish we were having more of a
conversation about this it's it's pretty
rare and I don't know did you happen to
see that crazy tweet by CNN's unrivaled
sources brian Stelter who had this
anonymous source that told him that
trumps leaving it up to the governor's
as if that's somehow scary I mean I
would prefer that the governor's have
more choice but huh how do you it is the
way the Constitution is written it's
crazy look at these people look at these
people he's leaving it up to the
governor's to decide that guy's a total
fascist what no that's the way it's
supposed to be they everyone who was so
concerned that he would grab power when
he doesn't tell manufacturing what to
make they freaked out I don't know maybe
your definition of fascist is the
opposite of mine but that's what the
president should be doing saying no I'm
not going to take over corporations and
tell them what to do I'm going to ask
them I'm not gonna tell them I'm not
going to I'm not gonna
tell States what to do and you know what
honestly the governor's should not be
telling the local cities what to do the
mayors should say in our town this is
what's right in our village our city
this is what's right and the governor
can help coordinate it's always power to
the people the closer you get to the
house the more important it becomes any
Trump the bad guy here yeah but what do
you say to the people cuz I hear it all
the time Glenn because you're singing my
tune I say these types of things and
people say well if you leave it all up
to the local officials one city might be
doing the right thing but the city next
door might be doing something terrible
and we know viruses don't care about
borders and things like that how do you
manage that Ben the virus doesn't care
about borders of course it does why
would we stop all air travel from China
of course it does you you just have to
defend your border as a town if somebody
next year the town next to you well then
you're not coming into our town I'm
sorry you know IIIi don't know how to do
it but it's an imperfect system as
Winston Churchill said it's mm-hmm it's
the worst system except for everything
else right so I mean it's not a perfect
system by any stretch of the imagination
but you have to trust the people it is
the people it is their rights I just saw
a video of someone being shut down and
the police officer saying your rights
have been suspended yeah thought my
rights have been suspended how do you
suspend inalienable rights oh I know you
can't you can't suspend rights you can
say for for health purposes but only the
state can do that not the federal
government and by the way what the guy
was doing was sitting in his car where
they were gonna have church services
where they were all gonna be socially
distance from each other so it wasn't
even as if in the car violated with the
windows rolled up with the windows
rolled up how afraid are you generally
that
we're just gonna kind of keep giving
away these things that that the time the
calendar will keep marching and slowly
yeah we won't go in our cars we won't
leave our house suddenly walking your
dog will be a problem and you know it
can only go in the backyard or just like
the endless cascade of things that we
can think of but I'm more worried about
the things that we can't think of that
they could come for so here's this
here's the worst part in the book
arguing with socialists yeah you have a
copy they're open I gotta Chapter six
yeah yeah open it up to Chapter six
okay I don't know if you if you saw that
one but it's how technology and modern
monetary theory can make socialism more
dangerous than ever
mm-hmm this is this was this was
assuming that the economic collapse
would come over a slow long period of
time that the economic collapse would
and joblessness would happen maybe
because of Technology the in that
chapter I outline what happens in that
situation where it's lots of joblessness
the first thing that happens is the
government needs to spend more money and
so they start to print more money
printed in the last few weeks more money
then we we digitized more money than we
could have printed in a year you
literally could not print that there's
not enough trees to print the amount of
money that we have just digitized in a
two or three week period so not about
their gold anymore it's not even about
the dollars because we can't print them
fast enough now we're just truly in a
sort of imaginary it's situation so it
is called it is called modern monetary
theory have you ever heard of it Dave I
haven't I'm a capable man this is a huge
no no no the most people don't know it
it's a huge talking point for socialists
and here's why because they've always
been held to this standard of well how
are you going to pay for it so modern
pterri theory is well we'll just
digitize or print the money well that
sounds like old failed monetary policy
but this is new and the idea is is that
as long as everybody understands that
mm-hmm
we can just print the money and if we
need the money we're gonna have to tax
everybody to death but we're not gonna
need the money so we'll just make the
money and then we'll spend the money and
that will help us make more money modern
monetary theory and if there's inflation
we'll use price controls and we'll also
use taxes to make sure that people are
buying only the things that we want them
to buy this is total control of an
economy through a government through the
printing of dollars that's modern
monetary theory the Fed is doing it
right now but the UK Treasury the crown
just announced that they are using mana
modern monetary theory and they are
actually just printing the DA they're at
least admitting it we're doing it as
well in this chapter I talked about when
that starts the government is going to
know it needs tech and tech will know it
needs the government and so the tech and
the government will start to work
together to monitor people because
they'll need to monitor and track etc
etc the coronavirus has made chapter six
a reality it is you asked me you know
how nervous are you I'm terrified that
what I wrote in chapter six is happening
right now
okay so there's so much there so so
jumping from that which will sort of
lead us further into the book so how
much of this the situation that we're in
right now do you think was just because
our systems were collapsing in front of
us we were watching the medias system
collapse in front of us we were watching
academia collapse in front of us we were
watching the political establishment
collapse and that all of those collapses
and then you find a crisis that you can
throw in the middle of that
lead to this perfect stew where suddenly
numbers don't even mean anything and we
have new monetary policy okay so let me
let me answer it this way you know the
the Reichstag fire of course never let a
good crisis really correct
now the Germans said does let's separate
this from what we know let me give you
two aspects or two two answers on this
one the Germans said that that fire was
happening and then the the Nazis just
took advantage of it that's one version
the other version is no they started it
and they wanted it to burn and then they
used that fire so I don't think I don't
think that that is what happened here I
don't think anyone started this fire I
don't think that while I do believe that
this did come from bats that were you
know the specimens were collected by the
Chinese and brought to that lab it was
not released intentionally it was sloppy
so nobody created this crisis and then
it's a series of events that just spiral
out of control but I do believe at some
point somebody came in and went you know
this whole thing is melting down anyway
this might be a good time just up pull
the plug I do think that's a possibility
and we just have the craziest people in
charge yeah it's weird because we all
sort of become conspiracy theorists
theorists and then it's like well what's
really a conspiracy not because what
you're saying is it's not that it's some
coordinated thing necessarily but events
transpire and feed off each other and
next thing you know here we are and you
not only have events feed off each other
you do have bad actors for instance
China is now telling France we can help
you out all you want but you have to
take our 5g systems we'll give you all
the masks that you need but we'll only
sell them to you if you do so you have
bad actors do
that and I do think that there are those
who are in global positions be them
people that are you know in high tech or
in high finance or governments that do
want a different system that don't
believe in the system of the West and
they would like to use an opportunity to
their advantage I don't think it's a
conspiracy theory to think that people
you know actually believe don't let a
crisis go to waste especially since many
people in positions of power have been
saying it out loud recently you know if
you look at what the Fabian socialist
did in World War one we wouldn't have
gone to war if there weren't a group of
people that were saying this is actually
gonna work to our advantage we should go
to world war because we can change the
world closer to our heart's desire
that's what they did then and I think it
it plays some role here
so it's interesting because all of this
actually is sort of directly related to
why you're constantly arguing with
socialists but before we get into the
book specifically just one more thing on
this generally what do you make of the
role or the state of media right now I
know you and I are in agreement on just
watching mainstream media collapse and
in many and in many ways it should but
like just in the last couple days this
insane New York Times story that sort of
defended Biden because there's no
evidence even though that wasn't the
standard they held Brett Kavanaugh to or
or a million other examples I can give
lately of just you know Corona related
nonsense and you know two months ago
it's not going to be a problem now
they're there scream and fire I mean all
of this because that's another piece of
this that I think has just run Ram shot
basically across everybody and nobody
knows who to trust right now so it's a
crisis of trust in almost everything I
didn't when I was growing up we were in
the Cold War
with the Soviet Union and I remember
thinking as a kid
how could anyone believe Pravda how
could anybody believe that stuff the
answer turns out to be pretty easily
they can believe that because they want
to or they're invested in in believing
that you know to to turn around and say
ooh my side I've been on the wrong side
is takes a really honest person Dave
Rubin take somebody who is who has real
guts and it's rare at least early on
it's rare the people who are reading the
New York Times are watching CNN and all
of this garbage they they are so deep
into it now and if you watch the media
how many of them are saying in fact I
just I just saw something here a minute
ago
about how the press is yelling at Donald
Trump because he wants to open the
country up and he wants to tell all
these states open up ok but they were
yelling at him when he wouldn't close
all of the states because he said it's
the states that should decide so now
he's kind of flip-flopped but it's
interesting that they only wanted him to
take the power to control now to keep it
closed not to not to open it up keep it
closed it's it's astounding to me
watching the press how they're they're
almost wanting more death more
destruction more bad things to happen
because the the only loser really is
Donald Trump in their eyes to hell with
the country
to hell with with freedom to hell with
all of this stuff if Donald Trump if he
likes it it's got to be bad if he's
against it it's got to be good and and
they'll do anything anything it's it's
you
it's beyond Trump derangement syndrome
as a t-shirt slogan it is a real true
deep illness ya see I'm with you on this
and I've asked a couple guests this and
they've said no that no they don't
really want to crash the economy to feed
Trump but I actually think you know you
may remember about a year a year and a
half ago when Bill Maher said he would
gladly tank the economy to get rid of
Trump if that's what it takes and I do
think that the media establishment
they've gone in so deep it's like
they're the boy who cried wolf and it's
like well you missed Russia you missed
Ukraine and Pietschmann blah blah blah
and it's like now they see blood in the
water and they I think they ammonia they
almost have to take it as far as it can
go to prove that they're not amazing
there's something like that yeah they
they want this to be true they want this
to be true how they can say he's a
fascist and then yell at him when he
doesn't move like a fascist is crazy is
crazy
you all don't you end on it you've gone
over the edge
don't forget the other flip side of that
is they'll say he's Hitler and then
they'll say he's not doing enough I mean
it's like both sides of this coin I mean
yeah yeah you you can't you can't have
it both ways
they they hate their hatred for Donald
Trump is greater than their love of
country now they can say they love their
country because they're fighting Donald
Trump but they're not seeing it's
somebody who is somebody who is so
enraged yeah I'm trying to think of a
movie where I've seen this where the
person even might even have righteous
indignation where they're just so
enraged and they're just acting and now
they're starting to hurt everything and
people have to grab them and say stop it
stop stop
nobody's grabbing them nobody's stopping
them glad I know you can do Star Wars
all day with me I how about Anakin
Skywalker my Muslim are when it when he
chokes Padme right and then obi-wan has
to jump in and it doesn't end that well
for remainder know what as long as we're
doing Star Wars I'll ask you one more
thing about Kron and then we're going
to the book so I know that you have the
original I think there are three of them
you're gonna have to clean this up for
me three original Darth Vader masks if
there was ever a time in life for glenn
beck to walk out to the supermarket
wearing Darth Vader's helmet this would
be that time please tell me it would be
tell me no no I haven't I haven't done
that but I did see somebody in a
supermarket here in Texas wearing a
stormtroopers mask and I thought at
first it was funny until she took the
mask up and she had it you know the
bottom of the mask was here and her old
face was out and she's like who I don't
know how these people could breathe or
even see in these things she was not
joking she really put that on like this
will protect me oh my god
it's the thinning of the herd Dave it is
the thinning of the herd all right well
let's because we're people that don't
necessarily want that herd there now
let's focus on the book for a little bit
so I told you right before we started
that I got to book just a couple days
ago and this weekend I would basically I
had it on my coffee table in just every
couple hours I would pick it up read a
couple pages it's fun like you actually
wrote about politics in a fun with
cartoons and little memes and images and
all this stuff you wrote about some
pretty serious stuff in an actual fun
way so my first question really is was
that the plan like Oh everyone's getting
drugged over that with all this stuff
endlessly why not give them something
that it's not like because actually in
many ways this book is not designed to
read you know in one sit sit down or
over three nights it's sort of designed
to pick it up think about something put
it down and do it again
so I'm riddled with a D D and it's hard
for me especially nonfiction I can read
fiction nonfiction especially when it's
like boring or it's got numbers involved
and you're talking about economics and
everything you're like oh shut up and I
just can't get through them and so what
I did was
we pattern a book called arguing with
idiots and I know this is a little
redundant but arguing with idiots I
wrote about 10 years ago and I heard
from so many people who are now in their
20s and 30s that said when that came out
I loved that book and I used the hundred
pages at the end of the footnotes to go
back and I wrote papers on it or I used
it as arguments but I didn't quote you
I'm like that's brilliant that's exactly
what has to happen you can't I went in
if we found us something a stat or
something and we had it verified by the
Heritage Foundation I would go back and
say find a leftie organization find the
New York Times verifying this because
you need the argument that they will
accept they're not going to accept the
Heritage Foundation and and so it was an
easy way to read it it's a fun way to
read it exactly right I have not said
this out loud but I think it's more of a
bathroom book you know it's one of those
easy but in the bathroom and you pick it
up and you know you enjoy reading it and
you could pick it up on any page but I
did it so those with open minds could
actually see the best arguments on both
sides and do it in a fun way so one of
the things that one of the things that's
really interesting to me is that you
know in the last couple weeks that as
Bernie sputtered and now has dropped out
there's been a bunch of tweets by people
high-level people from his campaign I
think one of them was a deputy campaign
manager who tweeted out Oh finally we
can drop Democratic from democratic
socialism now I've been screaming this
for three years that this is the plan
they're sneaking it in you know they're
sneaking in the bomb and then once it's
in they'll unleash it and of course they
were gonna drop it are you surprised how
brazenly they've dropped it and not only
that but the second part of this will be
do you think they have to destroy Bernie
in the process now because he didn't win
he didn't get them there and ultimately
he'll just be an old rich white man who
played by the rules so
he has to be sacrificed at the altar of
their socialist God or whatever it is
maybe because it's just such a
destructive God that maybe I think
there's a chance he becomes Barry
Goldwater that gave birth to the Reagan
movement years later I think I don't
think he was the the one to bring it to
its finish that person remains to be
seen yet when it comes to when it comes
to you know whether it's I can't
remember what was the other part of your
question Dave I'm sure you should have
written it down well so first whether
they design this to destroy Bernie right
remember oh oh but dropping democratic
socialism really just Oh as an
eye-opening democratic yeah democratic
socialism is crazy first I really
believe that it was not Stalin but Lenin
who first used the Democratic socialists
because they were afraid of Communists
the Russians were afraid of the
Communists and he said no no no we're
democratic we're democratic socialists
and and so it's it's been a ruse from
the very beginning when I was at Fox I
remember there was a US News & World
Report it was a magazine when there were
magazines and it had on the cover about
three months into Barack Obama's term it
said we're all socialists now and I
remember holding that up on camera and
saying first of all I didn't think you
were socialists second of all what sort
of bubble do you live in where you can
declare for the entire country we're all
socialists now and I use that to say
they are dying to tell you who they
really are
they've been living undercover for so
long and they've been waiting for their
moment for so long
that at some point the mask is gonna
come off say damn right because this
system doesn't work and that's where
we're at we're at right yeah yeah we are
they are frothing at the mouth now like
you can feel there's a certain
excitement right now from AOC and Ilan
Omar and you also have Elizabeth Warren
who's been a little more quiet during
this and Bernie those are the four on
the cover but but with a ocn Ilhan Omar
there's a real frothing at the mouth the
real excitement right now like see none
of it works this is the you know hey oh
she had this tweet about late-stage
capitalism showing people in lines at
supermarkets in San Antonio what she
always fails to add is that yeah our
stores still get restocked unlike in
socialist countries yeah and that and
that as you said before it's messy
nothing nothing in a free society is
absolutely perfect but yes III do see
that the mask is dropping now and and so
that leads me to know there are they
really just communists actually that the
next mask that drops is the socialist
mask meaning that they won't even have
to you know it the system no so this is
something that I clear up in the first
chapter of the book communism is not the
bad one if you actually look at the
theories of Marx communism is the Utopia
we've switched these it was the Soviet
Socialist Republic okay it's the
socialist side that is that is the scary
side the the communism only happens when
we all live in a happy commune and we're
all saying oh you know what I'll give
you my stuff don't worry about it and
there's no big boss there's no guns
because you don't need it because
everyone has come to this this communist
or community ax and we all want to be
there so communism is the Utopia
socialism is the step between when you
have capitalists and then you have the
people who say I want this utopia it's
this middle part well you're gonna have
to do something to convince these people
who like capitalism
that you want to be over here and so you
slowly drag them in piece by piece and
then at some point you just have to
shoot all the other people that don't
agree with it so we can get to the happy
place right so this is what they're not
communist they are brutal socialists
that are willing to kill willing to do
whatever it takes because the ends
justify the means I mean this is what I
keep describing as this is Thanos from
The Avengers movies what did he have to
do yeah it is wipe wipe out half the
people in the universe to create yeah
the Utopia and as he said yeah I'm the
good guy because I was the only one
brave enough to do it and can I ask you
something Dave you live in Hollywood do
you people even watch some of the stuff
that they make every especially when it
comes to Marvel i watch these things
that I'm like right I mean it's not just
me right you're seeing that this is
making the freedom kind of message here
it's kind of making all of the
conservative or the libertarian point
you're right I don't
I don't do they read do the vibes leave
it of that do they read well you know
what I think I think you know this as
someone that's been around the block you
know a lot of the people here in
Hollywood which is which is very much
changing right now and I think after
Corona the the idea of celebrity and
these big-budget things I think this is
all gonna change but you know most of
these people privately of course they're
capitalists and more libertarian minded
in everything else they push nonsense
and a confused message while in their
own lives what do they want to do more
than anything else they want to be free
they want to earn their money they want
to spend it freely but they push a
message to everybody else it's like most
of our politicians that's just counter
to everything that the way they actually
act can you believe it Glen could you
actually believe that it's a you know
it's amazing I have I have talked to
some studio heads so these are the these
are the big bosses and they are
definitely capitalists and they said if
Bernie Sanders is the guy all of us are
gonna be voting for Donald Trump we'll
never say that because all the actors
and actresses there they all believe in
this crap
but they'll kill this industry he would
kill this industry and so I know there
are some capitalists out there they're
not they're not libertarians or
conservatives but they do like their
money and they know what socialism does
exactly all right so if you're gonna
argue with the Socialists I'm gonna ask
you the number probably the number one
question that I get asked when I go to
college campuses which is how do you
even initiate the conversation not if
you're going back right not if you're
Dave Rubin but if you're a young kid on
a college campus and the the terrible
ideas that you write about here are
taking root and many of your friends
have subscribed to them and you just
want to talk to them about freedom a
little bit some of this but they are
automatically gonna call you a Nazi and
a racist and all of that stuff what is a
trick have you learned any tricks
throughout this that would allow the
conversation - you know that's [ __ ]
yes yes so that was a key word a key
word Dave trick it cannot be a trick it
cannot be a smooth move let me let me
put this in I know you're agnostic or an
are you an atheist or an agnostic and
you're gonna really enjoy this other
book I have sitting here because I'm
going to talk about some things in a new
way I would say all right yeah I would
say I'm I would say I'm a functional I'm
a functional believer I would say at
this point sort of in the Jordan
Peterson sense of okay good yeah for you
okay that's that's good yeah okay well
let me just talk to you here about Jesus
sit for a second and and one thing that
I don't like about Christian Church let
me just go and just take on my church we
have missionaries that go out and I
don't mind the idea of missionaries and
you know talking into people about
things but what I what bothers me is how
do we get people to talk about Jesus how
do we get people to get closer to
baptism I don't know that sounds icky
how about we love people and we listen
to people and we seek out what they are
looking for in their life what are they
seeking most socialists I think the ones
who have not really thought it through
I'm not talking about the die-hard
diehard well at least most diehards I'm
talking about the people who are in it
because they see a system they were born
and they might maybe their first memory
is September 11th and they remember the
carnage and the chaos and you know it
was had stuff to do about big war
machines and it was about oil and money
and my dad might have lost his job or
the stock market shut down and it was
scary then my next big memory is 2008
and my mom and dad lost everything that
they had worked hard for and had to
start all over again and then
coronavirus hit and they lost everything
this system doesn't work this system is
only rewarding the really powerful and
the rich my folks struggle and I don't
want to I don't want to live my life
like my folks did believing in this
nonsense that if I heard somebody talked
to me about that I could relate to them
and I would agree with almost everything
they just said now we can have a
conversation because instead of
approaching them and trying to win the
argument I'm trying to ask them
questions to get to understand their
perspective how did they get there don't
talk to me about systems how did you get
here what are you really looking for and
if you're looking for the workers of the
world unite I move on if you're looking
to find a better way to live in harmony
live some natural principles live in
ways that will actually work and I don't
see this system is working ok great I'm
with you so now what are the problems
let's let's separate the baby from the
bathwater is there a baby in that
bathwater I think there is you may not
so
to find what that baby is and separated
from the bathwater yeah I guess the only
problem is is that well of course I make
sense but I guess the the only flaw
unfortunately is that we have just so
many young people that talk about
workers of the world unite or just the
evil patriarchy or just the the simple
versions as opposed to a complex human
version of understandable things that
you just laid out there that it makes
that conversation just hard to have well
it makes it hard to have in a crowd yeah
but nothing is ever really solved in a
crowd everyone wants to be heard
everyone wants to be listened to nobody
wants to be listened to somebody who's
just waiting for the opportunity to
spring they're there good news on them
they we have to empathize and really
truly listen or we're not going to make
any we're not gonna make any inroads and
because mainly because a lot of the
people who are arguing it they don't
even know what they're talking about
there's so many people on our side are
just spouting stuff that they heard from
somebody else and they haven't thought
it through we need we don't need a bunch
of followers we need leaders we need to
find people that really will have a
change of heart I said to you Dave two
years ago we were talking about
something and we disagreed on it and I
said I think I know you well enough to
know that you'll get there you'll get
there because it only makes logical
sense and you may have agreed with me at
that time kind of half-heartedly
and said yeah I could see that maybe
happening
and that's because I respect your
intellect and there are things that are
universally true we can look at it in
different ways we can argue it in
different ways but when it comes down to
it if you have a few things as your
guiding principles you will eventually
find your way down here
yeah well you know what I love you
defined you know what I'd love to do I
know in a couple weeks when I'm gonna be
on your show to talk about my book I lay
out all of these principles and we do
have some disagreements on some of these
things and we could spend let's do it
let's spend the entire conversation
discussing only the things we disagree
on it'll it'll actually be pretty
beautiful because I know there's a
couple I love that are that that you're
not going to agree with but how much of
this also is that when you when you have
a cover like this and you put these
people that it's a cartoon but they sort
of are cartoon characters a ocl on Omar
two leaves not on the cover but a bunch
of the squad they really do seem like
cartoon characters and they sort of it
makes sense that people like them want
to get into politics because their whole
ethos is about controlling people even
if even if you know it's presented as
freeing people as opposed to what I
think our side would roughly be which is
about freeing people you're not really
gonna want to get into politics like
it's a much harder sell to get a strong
person who doesn't want to rule your
life to get into politics which is about
ruling people's lives so there's an
asymmetry of there's an asymmetry of the
types of people fighting for these
political positions yes and it's a
problem libertarians are like herding
cats conservatives generally speaking
not all of them but generally speaking
they're entrepreneurial they have
entrepreneurial spirit and so they just
kind of go do their thing and and those
who those who see society as a
collective they're on the left and they
they're raised you know and and groom
themselves to be somebody who's a
busybody who's caring about everybody
else's business and so they have to be
in charge of something and so they do it
just it's it's a lopsided lopsided
scenario here but you know it's
interesting you bring up their cartoon
characters and they are cartoons but if
you're if you look so my and and this is
a this a statement really from the last
book was a
arguing with idiots and I don't know if
you remember that cover but I was I had
dark eye makeup on to make me look
really crazy and I was in a like a it
was a it was a Russian uniform and I was
standing like a dictator and I remember
I walked into FoxNews when that book
came out Roger Ailes held the book up
and said why the hell would you ever
look like this why would you ever put
that picture out and I said because
that's what half the country sees me and
I want to poke fun at myself because
they see me as a cartoon character and
they have to stop seeing me and others
like cartoons so it's kind of the same
thing the facts in here are not cartoons
but the exaggerations by you know these
eco socialists that we're all going to
die in 12 years that is cartoon that is
a cartoon so it's actually or not can
you talk about why they use that as a
tactic this sort of everything is
collapsing and it's collapsing now it's
all always about you know 12 years from
now and it's five months from now and
you have a funny thing with Aloha know
with a OC and the cow farts because we
have to rejigger everything now
otherwise MassDEP drowning so here's
what is it's the only reason and the
only way to get socialism to be as
popular as it is in a country as wealthy
and where the poorest among us are in
the top 1% of the world you have to
create other problems we had in in the
last two years we have had fewer deaths
per capita than any time in American
history we have had more jobs and a
higher percentage or I should say a
lower percentage of unemployment than
ever before at least in the last 100
years we have it really really good we I
mean people who
quote-unquote poor have iPhones you're
not poor and have a phone let alone an
iPhone so you have to create a boogeyman
and the left it always says that that's
what you know the the right does with
you know with terrorists or with
communists in Russia or whatever that
it's just a boogeyman it's not real
so they'll deny real killers in many
cases they will embrace them Fidel
Castro even Hitler Mussolini they were
all embraced by the left and they will
come up with these boogeyman to be able
to frighten us because you have to have
something to save it's about forcing
people to do something because it's
right for the collective they just are
not smart enough to see it so we need
your help
to round these people up to try to
convince them but then they just won't
see the error of their ways well that
kind of goes into the idea of socialism
too that a few elites know better and
you're one of them you just know better
all right that's how it works all right
so take Reagan is how what's frightening
is how far we went under a good economy
if we are indeed going to hit 30%
unemployment as the Federal Reserve says
32.4 percent unemployment is what they
predict by June 1st if we get anywhere
close to that and it doesn't turn around
when we turn the engines back on Dave we
are we are going to be I made this
prediction in 2008 if we go down this
road we will make Hitler look like
rookies because we are we are a great
nation with great power and if we go
dark we will use that power in ways the
world has never seen
I shudder to think what we will do to
our own people and to the rest of the
world with great power and dark dark
collective
horses in charge oh man well if that
answer was the shutting off the engine
answer now give me the to wrap this
whole thing up give me some hope here
give me the give me the answer that the
engine can get on and functional before
we hit rock bottom in Sydney yeah it's
an easy one we just have to remember
that our rights are inalienable meaning
no man can change them we don't get them
from men we don't get them from the
government you can't suspend my rights I
have inalienable rights when we remember
who we are we we can take if if I were
on an island and I had to pick a team
from a country to help me put together
airplane parts that are just scattered
all over a field and make some form of
transportation I would pick the
Americans every single time we will
figure out a way you know the the Enigma
machine which was the unbreakable code
of the of the Germans and there was a
great movie out the touring ten about
the Turing test and Alan Turing who was
this great great brilliant mind broke it
and I think two or three years it took
them and they had a an Enigma machine
what isn't told is that two Americans on
a Navy ship in the Pacific didn't have a
machine and figured out and broke that
in about six months so Americans figure
things out weird we're just good at that
it's that entrepreneurial spirit if
given the chance when this thing opens
up the the cure or the treatment or the
testing or whatever it is that we need
will come from I think either Israel or
the United States of America the answers
will come to rebuild the technology will
be there and the Spirit will be there if
we don't allow the media and quite
honestly those who are so eager to
control people that they kick the snot
out of our spirit over and
again we're not only gonna survive will
thrive will thrive because that's what
we do I'm with you Beca our work is cut
out for us but I don't have anything
better to do to you I don't either
I'm not gonna spend the rest of my life
not doing that exactly all right well
we're gonna put a link to the book right
down below stay safe and one of these
days we'll get to do this interview in a
couple weeks
yeah I know talk to you in a couple of
weeks when your book comes out I can't
wait send it to me so I can read it in
advance we're gonna get one out to you
today
all right good see any of my friend good
thanks if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlists all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell